be able to see it so I'm being told this
is going to be very similar to the um
peard deal where we will see it on
Paramount plus um on Save the Thursday
but that will only be in the United
States it will then air internationally
on Prime and Paramount plus then the
next day so this is a three-day
basically delivery Paramount Plus on the
Thursday Prime on the Friday everywhere
else in the world on Paramount that they
deliver Paramount on the Saturday this
is how that will work and for that Prime
will actually pay Paramount up to 30% of
the production costs for the show now
that is a decent chunk of money for the
deal they're getting why have Paramount
done this well as we've told you
repeatedly it's not if but when with
this series it was always going to
happen but Paramount desperately need to
cut costs bosses over at Paramount have
decided that costs need to drop by at
least 30% across all of the TV shows